hey guys I'm back in and we're going to
do a video on something very interesting
now in some of the other videos that I
created I talked about cancer living on
sugar right but cancer also can use
another fuel okay so it actually
actually has two different types of fuel
so if we actually understand the nature
of cancer in the difference between a
normal cell and a cancer cell we can
actually gain insights and how to
control cancer and eliminate it okay so
let's just take it from the beginning
what triggers cancer well you have
radiation chemicals stress and there's a
wide range of things that can actually
initiate cancer but what happens is
these things trigger damage in the
mitochondria so the first trigger in the
chain of events is damage to the
mitochondria what is the mitochondria
it's an energy factory that basically
produces all your energy in your body
what happens next is that the body then
in its attempts to survive adapts the
metabolism the entire metabolic system
is adapted in a cancer cell going from a
normal metabolism to something that's
more primitive and it's a compensatory
type thing where the body is
compensating from the damage and it's
called fermentation basically you
ferment sugar so you're breaking down
sugar as a fuel and in without oxygen
now there might be oxygen there but
cancer cells don't use oxygen so we have
fermentation of sugar and an amino acid
called glutamine so cancer can live on
glucose or glutamine cancer and tumors
cannot live on ketones okay this is why
the ketogenic diet is very very
important to stop fueling this cancer so
we want to cut the sugar down and feed
the body ketones because normal cells
can live on ketones but cancer and tumor
cells cannot but we also have to
confront glutamine so you might think
wow I'm just going to avoid glutamine in
the die
and it'll be fine right well the problem
is glutamine is so widespread in your
diet it's almost impossible to get rid
of it it's in meats it's an eggs it's an
fish it's in vegetables that's and nuts
it's in seeds so what are you gonna eat
right now there's some amazing research
being done right now using the ketogenic
diet with something called Don which
tends to inhibit glutamine okay so it's
a it's a chemical that you can consume
that will block this right here but
there's some side effects but it sounds
promising so it's just the research is
just beginning right now and you're
going to be seeing a lot more of this in
the coming years but the research right
now is quite startling on the
combination of doing the ketogenic diet
and blocking this amino acid in the
complete destruction of cancer cells and
I'm going to put some links down below
and it's a quite fascinating but there
are things that people can do right now
to reduce glutamine okay not eliminate
it but reduce it for example green tea
has certain chemicals that will inhibit
glutamine and peppers all types of
peppers also have certain properties
that can inhibit glutamine as well but
the biggest thing that will reduce this
is intermittent fasting so in summary
the key with cancer is understanding
cancer and the problem really is in the
damaged mitochondria and the
fermentation okay and the fuel sources
and then dealing with these fuel sources
because the problem right now is in the
last 40 years there's been billions and
billions of dollars spent on cancer
research with very little progress if
any at all okay so this is very very
exciting where this is going and more
importantly it's the prevention of
things that can trigger cancer avoiding
chemicals eating healthily eating
organic keeping your stress down
avoiding excessive radiation to keep
your mitochondria really really strong
combining with a healthy ketogenic Plan
okay consuming a lot of leafy greens and
cruciferous vegetables that can actually
protect the mitochondria very very
important and
in a minute fasting okay all right and I
hope I increased your awareness on this
other source of fuel for cancer cells
thanks for watching
so we've been getting a lot of success
stories but I don't have your success
story yet so click the link down below
and upload you before and after I want
to actually hear about your success
story I want to see your before and
afters and every week we do featured
success stories so click the link down
below and share your success